it's almost like the world has ended and
I'm kind of the last person there my
name is Steph lawless and I'm a
photojournalist I pretty much known for
traveling across the country capturing
and documenting some of the most broken
and abandoned sections of America
this section of America had a lot of
American manufacturing jobs a lot of
blue-collar
steel jobs auto manufacturers and a lot
of those jobs were outsourced overseas
nice the cities have abandoned factories
that closed and resulted in a phantom
neighborhoods and abandoned schools and
abandoned churches in abandoned homes
Paul's work communal spaces they weren't
a place necessarily to shop before there
was computers this is where you win this
is where you hung out you you met people
you talked to people and to see that
gone even though it had this
capitalistic ugly side to it there was
something beautiful there I love this
country to death but I want people to
look at my images and see the beginning
of the end of the greatest economic
machine that the world has ever seen
America